hi it's metrix and mitel and i'm katya
and today we're going to be testing our
friendship using this brand new
buzzfeed bff test it's going to be
thrilling and probably
uh will illustrate how well we do not
know each other
what we lack in friendship we make up
for in
new york times best-selling authorship
go through this list one by one with
your bff and check off the ones you get
correct about your bff
full birthday do you know my full
birthday um i bet you i know the month
yeah i know you are nope um you are
august 23rd
1989 yes how did you
know that well i know you're seven years
younger and i know your birthday
i don't even know the month of your
birthday
the only person's birthday i know is my
boyfriend because i've had to ask enough
times like i'm embarrassed
that's the only thing i liked about
facebook tells you what's the reminder
we'll see as i get older i'm sure that
i'll ch i'll move it around oh their
middle name
michael joseph yes yes government name
on fleek
astrological sign well this is
controversial because
you were you used to call yourself a leo
but now you're a virgo yeah
that costs the day of yeah it's the
virgo and you are
an aries oh nope oh my god
are you a capricorn no are you a taurus
oh so your birthday's not in april it's
march
what is it their age when they came out
of the closet i feel like this is a
trick question
what if i was never trapped in the
closet what if i never aged
i'm going to say 17. i think because i
think you would have done it right
before leaving home i don't think you
would have waited
yeah i did it at home and i was on my
way to therapy that's when to do it
honestly because then you get to go
properly i had to
because my therapist was going to talk
to my parents about me being gay
i love that your therapist was like i'm
gonna get out you
tired of the [ __ ] tired of the drama
when did you formally come out i'm going
to say
16 18. i called home from like sophomore
year of college like right before
christmas being like
in my mom who cares the only reason my
mom cares because she was pissed that i
thought she'd be mad she was like i
thought i did it better than this that
you would think i wouldn't be
compassionate about this
i love that your mom rules yeah she well
my mom's like a hippie
my mom was like you know two edibles in
being like you think i care
also my name is gooch who has a mullet
so like there was a primer in this
family well i got it and you did it
first time they did drag as in what i
was three years old
yeah it's hard to say like i remember
being a kid and putting on like
scrunchies and girls
i wear wigs all the time with the kid
when was she booked was yours at um
in milwaukee yes it was you know let's
do
the time warp again oh rocky horror
picture show yes
at the uh the the good old clam shot the
tactics yeah
is that a long john silvers actually
yeah i'm gonna guess your first paid gig
was
post college i'm assuming yep post
college yeah okay number one
pop queen i actually think i know yours
you love janet jackson
yeah but no she's not my number one bite
is it that russian [ __ ] yeah
it's not right what's her name damn it
that was so close
your number one pop queen dolly parton
dusty springfield i think that counts i
think dolly counts as a popcorn
their biggest pet peeve i hate when
people stop posing
i don't know what you hate i hate
everything and then nothing
you know going to work yeah going to
work um showing up on time
getting dragged getting a drag getting
into a car i would say your pet peeve is
maybe smokers smoking
disgusting gross snacks it's not my fave
i guess i don't get a point because
nothing bothers you great have you ever
been on like a date with someone where
they're rude to the wait staff and
you're like
no because if i had i would i would have
left the celebrity who caused your gay
awakening
no on claude van damme yes absolutely
yours would be
what i don't know um we've talked about
it but i don't know if you'll remember
it
willie nelson no not willie nelson paul
wright not paul read
i mean probably paul redd yeah paul ryan
okay from clueless
zack morris say by the bell like when he
looked right at the camera it was like
oh yeah i was more of a slater girl oh
you still can because that
girl looks the same the same and he's
got a great ass
current celebrity crush you know what
i'm gonna say christian
absolutely christian zamora got my
voices mine are pretty consistent
willie nelson brooks and kid rock
yes it's kid rock i want to be on rock
of love please thank you
the first thing they grab if the house
was on fire i was gonna say that
russian bejeweled knife yeah with yeah
the you know with the eyeballs probably
your guitar
maybe um one of my barbies is worth
about four grand you know what's funny i
talked about this in the book just to
quote it i'm just gonna go there
if my house caught on fire on honey with
this beverly grove 1930s wiring tick
tock honestly
i would grab three things a red bull my
still-in-the-box 1971 malibu barbie and
my makeup bag
in or out of drag i love to invoke the
smoke and mirrors of cosmeceuticals
and if i'm going to tell my harrowing
tale of escape to the 911 first
responders
i'm not going to do it with tired eyes
so concealer let's just say concealer
one piece of drag you couldn't live
without
for you wig i was gonna save for you
lash a hundred percent
worsted best drag race look i think your
best one was your jane doe latex
i believe that you're right and i think
your best one was your
your red latex yeah jane doe latex hi
jane doe
and then your worst one nina kate right
nina kate yeah i mean the
hello kitty oh yeah there you go yeah
that was pretty pretty i'm taking that
point and then
i'm going to say your um miss mandarin
uh fortune cookie
yeah for a number of reasons that yeah
for acceptable look
most embarrassing moment from drag race
i would say your snatch came in almost
100
and for you i would say oh the diet that
was the sienna no no the lip sync um
go amazon airways oh [ __ ] yeah that was
bad
go to lip sync song
which i can't do anymore uh what nine to
five barbie girl
oh if i lost my music and i walk in and
they're like do you have a number i just
told the dj put on aqua barbie girl
i barely know the words and they don't
care what their real life sounds like
and being able to impersonate it where's
that like it's just a scream
that's it it's not like i'm trying to be
killed with god for yourself
you sound you say it's like a laugh
after you like hit the biggest bong rip
that's what you sound like doing it like
wow
i'm taking the point oh yeah i got 9 out
of 15.
i got 9 out of 15. equally bad friends
we just friendship so good we both put
the effort here
our friendship works because we barely
know each other there's so much more
ground to cover in the future you can't
be disappointed by someone you literally
know nothing about
our web show returns for more episodes
august 5th on wow presents plus